there is a campaign right now that is
looking to revise history okay it's a
very aggressive campaign in fact that is
armed with cease and desist letters and
this is a campaign being fought by
Donald Trump's campaign for re-election
panicked about coronavirus as they
should be they are now going around
trying to scrub and remove evidence that
Trump was using the term hoax when
discussing coronavirus just weeks ago
feels like months ago or even longer
that we thought maybe this coronavirus
thing won't be a big deal but Donald
Trump was calling it a hoax just a few
weeks ago and the first move that the
Trump campaign made
uh 10 days ago was to start saying no no
no he never meant the virus was a hoax
what he meant was that Democrats are
doing a hoax by distorting this or by
trying to use it against Trump or
whatever uh at one point Trump said that
Democrats were victims of the hoax
sometimes they perpetrated it like it
was completely incoherent every time
Trump would say something different but
the idea was that Donald Trump believed
coronavirus would be no big deal that's
the whole point of what he was saying
that has been proven very very wrong
whichever of these conflicting and
contradictory versions of What Trump
meant by hoax you believe it's bad for
Trump no matter what for this video to
be floating around there's no question
about it so now they're taking it up a
notch the Trump campaign is trying to
get these videos removed from the
internet any video in which he uses the
word hoax in connection with coronavirus
is bad for Donald Trump now there is a
uh pack which has has been issued a
cease and desist letter the pack is
called priorities USA action it's a pack
that supports Democratic candidates and
they have received a cease and desist
letter from the Trump Campaign which
says you are airing patently false
misleading and deceptive advertisements
made by a political action committee
they are sending the cease and desists
to TV stations telling them stop airing
this ad from this pack let's look at the
ad so that we all understand what we're
talking about it is
pretty solid as far as an ad goes you're
going to hear Trump downplaying the
virus while on screen if you're watching
the case numbers are rising imagine that
if you're just listening today while you
hear this audio there is a growing
number of cases on screen the
coronavirus this is their new hoax we
have it totally under control it's one
person coming in from China One day it's
like a miracle it will disappear when
you have 15 people and within a couple
of days it's going to be down to close
to zero we really think we've done a
great job in keeping it down to a
minimum I like this stuff I really get
it people are surprised that I
understand it now I don't take
responsibility at all
priorities USA action is responsible for
the content of this ad so the this is
their new hoax is what they're taking
issue is there's that they're saying
that is out of context it makes it sound
like Trump was saying the virus is a
hoax when that's not what he meant he
meant that Democrats are using this to
attack him just like they did with the
Witch Hunt hoax just like they did with
the impeachment hoax that's the argument
that they're trying to make now what's
really going on is that they're
panicking they're panicking over the
reality that there is nothing hoax like
about coronavirus there never was
anything hoax likes hoax like about the
seriousness with which Democrats were
dealing with coronavirus from the
beginning they want to pretend that it's
about this one ad being deceptive or out
of context but even if you win that
argument and Grant that okay Trump
didn't say the virus is a hoax in this
particular video Even if you grant that
Trump has been downplaying the entire
thing from the beginning and as a result
we have a higher death toll we have half
of our states doing nothing
in terms of physical distancing and
shutting things down everything Trump
has been saying all along has been
proven to be false Trump brought uh you
know H1N1 as something that Obama
bungled and said this isn't going to be
as bad well we now have a worldwide
death toll in the 20 000 soon going to
the 30 thousands and Trump and his
campaign are concerned about getting
videos off of the internet and off of TV
rather than actually dealing with the
problem this entire game of you know
what he meant to say it's literally
revisionist history and of course at any
time they could pull out the entire it
was just a joke thing they've done it
before it seems as though they realize
that in this case saying it was a joke
when Trump said it would look very bad
given the numbers if you haven't been
following the numbers we just went it
took us months to get to a hundred
thousand Global cases we just went from
400 000 Global cases to 500 000 Global
cases in two days and Donald Trump is
focused on getting videos pulled from TV
and the internet where he uses the word
hoax in the context of the coronavirus
the priorities have been wrong from day
one they continue to be wrong and this
is all posturing from November that's
what this is fundamentally coming down
to decisions about do we open up the
economy or don't we
it's all about re-election the Easter
thing there may even be influence from
Christians there wanting uh East the
things open back up by Easter there's an
interesting article about that that I
read yesterday can fauci be allowed to
say stuff or is it damaging because he
contradicts Donald Trump everything is
Optics everything is stock markets the
economy money blah blah blah when the
reality is if the death toll gets to
where some of the worst estimates
suggest it could if we don't do anything
that is going to be far worse for the
country than dealing with a stock market
decline and high unemployment rates for
a few months that we really should be
buckling down completely if you disagree
with my take but if there's people in
the audience who think we shouldn't
actually be closing down more now and
just grinning and bearing it and waiting
if you have a different approach what I
want to hear from you is
give me a metric give me data that
suggests we've turned the corner and we
should be looking at opening things back
up I'm searching for it I've been
looking I can't find any such data I'm
on Twitter at dpacman if you want to let
me know
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches giving you 15 off your entire
order when you go to davidpackman.com
watch don't pay thousands of dollars for
a high quality watch that looks great
because you don't have to all of
vincero's watches are made with high-end
materials masterfully built and they
look like something you'd spend a ton of
money on but every vincero watch ranges
from about 150 to 300 bucks I went over
to their website and picked out the
Bellwether in silver and white really
nice elegant look it's a chronograph
style wore it to a Gala over the weekend
and a lot of people ask me where's the
watch from really really great look
totally different they also sent me the
altitude in matte black and red a much
more rugged view of what a watch can
look like really like it as well as well
as the athletic strap it's a new year
it's a new decade it's time to
re-establish your style add something
new to your look and a high quality
watch is the perfect way to do that you
can get 15 off vincero's entire
collection when you go to
davidpackman.com watch